the clear winner
okay i'm here to talk about the invented
web
uh pretty much there's a problem stuff
is happening on the internet and you
want to do stuff when that stuff happens
um very descriptive description very
technical i hope everyone can grock that
um first a warning unexpected
presentation is unexpected
hello hello can anyone hear me all right
all right so like i was saying uh stuff
is happening on the internet and you
want to do stuff when that stuff happens
a bit of a warning i did not think i'd
be presenting today i didn't even think
i would be here um the tickets sold out
for jsconf before i bought one i came
down on friday i wanted to party with
you guys meet some people and i was
lucky enough to win scurvy comp so i'm
here today um there's going to be some
badly created slides which i made last
night on the boat and this morning
and i'm a little nervous so just bear
with me
web hooks okay so
in the world of the evented web it's
really all about web hooks so
what is a web hook
there's no rfc for web hooks there's no
standard definition there's no committee
most people have dealt with web hooks
before if you do web development usually
they're presented as a restful web hook
there's a bit of information out about
this at webhooks.org jeff lindsay is
kind of the pioneer working with this
stuff i haven't seen much other
information out there
and
yeah the definition of a web hook is
kind of ambiguous right now so most
people think of restful web hooks you
have um an arbitrary url that's not a
real url don't go there
and it's just sitting there and it's
waiting for an http request when the
http request comes in some arbitrary
action is going to happen and this is
kind of how most people think of web
hooks today
so i kind of disagree with this restful
web books are not web hooks they're a
type of web hook
they are a of web hook yes
excellent
so yes a restful web hook is just a type
of web hook
so we're going to kind of restate our
assertion here stuff is happening on the
internet and you want to do stuff when
that stuff happens
so an incoming http request
does count as stuff
but there's way more things that you
could be listening for not just an
incoming http connection
so first who is this guy with the domo
hat and who led him on stage hi
my name is morock squires i'm a software
developer from nyc
um i participate in the nyc js group a
little bit um this is my github i don't
do twitter um i have a fake facebook you
can't find me
so uh yeah check me out on github
i've been involved in a few internet
hijinks for those who know me they're
not really appropriate to be speaking
about here
i've been banned from most online
services at least once that's the ban
hammer
i even got banned from github they
unveiled me thank you very much
for those who don't know the story i
created a bit of a script that forced
people to watch a library that i created
and it went pretty far before they
caught on but uh yeah so i'm not going
to do that again because getting banned
from github would probably be
problematic
and i want scurvy cough because i could
yell louder than everybody else
so also i'm here because of hookia which
is a product or a open source project
that i've made i like to call it yahoo
crack pipes
the website's up right now it's hook dot
io it's pretty rudimentary you'll
probably be able to break it if you try
hard enough
so i'm going to give you a very brief
history of hokio
this is the github commit log i've got
88 watchers i'm pretty proud of that
they're legitimate watchers not ones
that i forced
um you can see from the commit log i
actually do have a full-time day job
which i'm not allowed to work on other
projects so you can kind of see i don't
sleep much
uh this is hokio the main application
it's about yeah nine thousand insertions
this is the front end for hook yo
another 7000 or so
and i started this project two months
ago and the first line of code is
written two months ago so it's been
pretty busy for the past two months with
all of these commits
and yes so what's tokyo hook yo is a few
things hokio is a standalone server
hokio is a common js module hokio is a
freemium software as a service tokyo was
open source mit licensed and hokio is a
standard interface for building webio
okay so
oh one more thing hook yo was 100
javascript in node.js
no js owns your face
that's uh ryan as you can see
so i didn't really explain anything i
just kind of threw out a bunch of buzz
words so yes what exactly is hook you
aside from these things i just described
well hokio is a web hook platform
and yes platform is probably a terrible
word to use maybe it's an application
framework but let's not get boggled down
by the semantics hokio is going to
listen for stuff to happen on the
internet and when that stuff happens
it's going to do other stuff
so in the world of hookieo we have two
main concepts we have web hook
definitions and we have web hook
protocols
a web hook definition
comes in two different flavors there's a
web hook listener and a web hook action
web hook definitions are common js
modules
so
pretty much what happens with the web
hook is that it's going to listen for an
action
or an event and when that happens it's
going to perform an event or an action
arbitrary it doesn't matter what it
listens for it doesn't matter what the
action is going to be so for the most
part when i say listening there's two
ways that hokio can listen for events on
the internet it can pull which is not
really a traditional way of listening
since it's actually going out and
pulling a resource but what happens is
that hokio can actively you know request
a resource on an interval which is
polling and it's going to listen for a
change listen for content listen for
something
or hook you can use sockets hokio will
open up a socket and wait for data so if
you think of a restful web hook that's
really just an http socket waiting for
an incoming connection
actions so in a web hook definition we
have actions well what are they they're
just arbitrary actions they can be
literally anything it doesn't even need
to be over the wire it could be
something for system administration who
knows
in most cases it will be an outgoing
http request
so kind of look at a little bit of code
here this is a sample hookio webhook
listener
this is for
incoming http requests so if you take a
look at this code there's not really too
much going on here
we define the definition we give it a
configuration
and then we give it a handler
here we have a hokio webhook custom
action definition and again there's not
really much going on here this is for
sending emails and all we have is a uh
config for two
and then the body it's very simple i
don't think we have a subject in here
yet
and
yeah as you can see these are just
common js modules and a little bit of
json in a definition so
it doesn't really look like they do
anything it just looks like their
configuration and validation options and
that's kind of the whole point is that
all the business logic is offloaded to
something we call hookio protocols
and
probably not the best word a lot of the
problem with working on this project has
kind of been defining new definitions as
we go along
so a hokio protocol is just a cluster of
business logic for doing stuff
in most cases your hookier protocol
would be a thin wrapper for
communicating with a third-party api
also hokio protocols are valid common js
modules
so what protocols are available in
hookieo the first version um we've got a
bunch of stuff in here um you know we
can parse hamill markdown mustache we
can communicate with s3 we can
communicate with twitter their streaming
api and their plane api we have a timer
which is what a lot of the polling is
based off of it's an interval
we have a documentation protocol which
is pretty sweet
recently just got mint going i don't
know if you guys know about this it's a
documentation
project for node.js applications and
javascript applications which is pretty
sweet so the documentation protocol
every time hokio starts up for the first
time we actually auto generate the
documentation based on some static
markdown files and then based on the
exports from our common js modules so if
you're making changes in the code and
you restart the application it's auto
documented instantly which is pretty
neat
and again protocols are just clusters of
logic so
for instance the http protocol handles
incoming http connections and outgoing
http connections but you can make a
hookieo protocol for anything
okay so let's back up a second how did i
build all of these protocols and write
15 000 lines of code in two months
i didn't
the trick is sub modules node.js has a
really strong community and there's a
lot of really good people doing really
good work and i've just been stealing it
all
so um
but going back to protocols this is kind
of what we have right now and uh what
we're planning for the next release
we're gonna have uh github api access
we're gonna have a git protocol for
doing system level git stuff
um working on a really cool rss burner
parser from you know aggregating a bunch
of rss feeds
we want to integrate with the facebook
connect api
and then some of the really interesting
stuff is i've been working with my
friend eli um who just did
js dom he goes by temp var if anybody
knows him we're working on doing server
side uh support for yui which came out a
few weeks ago jquery
and uh just html parsing so the
interesting thing here is that we can
begin to scrape pages and then perform
uh client-side selectors server-side so
you don't need to learn any new selector
library if you're familiar with jquery
or sizzle or yui you can start to use
that stuff server-side so i'm sure a lot
of people here have had to deal with
scraping
static web pages and it's a pain in the
ass the traditional approach is you know
pearl and a whole bunch of regex going
back a few years and it just doesn't
work
so being able to leverage some of these
existing technologies which have been
really well defined on the front end is
a very interesting thing
so yes the node community is awesome
i've gotten a lot of help there's a lot
of really good people writing modules
github is pretty amazing as well
everyone's on github that's involved
with the node community you know you can
i don't need to tell you guys how github
works
i like to think i'm a core contributor
but i haven't submitted anything to node
itself i just yell at other people to
fix their modules which is kind of fun
i'm in the irc room all the time i might
be the most active person there
in there right now
i'll go back to that
so hookio the development plan like i
stated before really i'm not trying to
reinvent any wheels um people are doing
really good work and i just want to
leverage that so the current plan is to
just fork and steal all of the best
common js modules
and then four can steal all the best
work from the node community and then of
course integrate with every single web
service we can find
uh create a lot of github issues and
hope somebody fixes them
i like to join the github irc room on
occasion and say hey i've been creating
issues on my github project but nobody's
fixing them is github down
yeah they don't like that too much
and of course part of the development
plan is to yell at more people on irc
so now that we've kind of talked about
what hook yo is like well how could we
use it how could i build an application
on hookio as a developer
so first i kind of want to talk about
the hokio api
so the api for hookeyo is exposed
through different interfaces so you can
communicate to the api through many
different ways um json rpc is the
current way that it's exposed but we'll
get a little bit into that later so at
the lowest level the hokio api is
exposed through a common js module so
you just require hookio the common js
module
and then you have access to hookieo.api
which is the top level api calls
some other interesting things is that
if you're importing hookio as a common
js module you tend to use in that
fashion you also have access to the
underscore library by jeremy i don't
know if he's in here right now
underscore is a functional library for
javascript it's pretty cool
you have access to the raw db command so
if you want to bypass the api you can
just go straight to the db layer and
start running queries
um you have access to hookio.debug which
is really neat it is an alias for node
debug which is another project i've been
working on it's a asynchronous web
console for debugging for node.js
so um i also added a few more options
for hookio you can log to a file you can
log to the console and of course to the
asynchronous web console
and then um i've started to add some
flow control libraries by tim caswell
step is in there right now which is
pretty neat so
now that we have this idea of the hokio
api
we're going to talk about using hokio as
a software as a service so like i said
before hokio is a standalone application
a common js module and a software as a
service so that's a little confusing
because the name of the project is also
the name of the website which is also
the name of the software as a service
which is also the name of the common js
module
so if you want to use the software as a
service now it's available at hooke.io
as a json rpc
we're going to be investigating exposing
it you know maybe xml rpc maybe soap
there's a lot of options we could do
working on jsonp support so you can
start doing some cross browser stuff i'm
sorry cross domain stuff
so using hook yo as a software as a
service you can build a standalone
client
just on the front and it's just going to
talk over javascript so we have a
browser side javascript api which wraps
the hokio api
in js and then communicates over the
json rpc so if you're using hokio you
know as a common js module and you
become familiar with the api calls it's
going to be identical for the json rpc
and pretty much anywhere you expose the
api through any interface all the calls
are one-to-one so you don't need to
learn different things
so okay hook you as a standalone server
really simple all you have to do is just
clone it run the submodule update we'll
be doing packaging for later versions
but for now they're sub modules and then
you just node server.js
so the interesting thing here is if you
look at the actual server.js file all
we're doing is just requiring hokio and
starting it up
so
uh
part of the problem when i've been
developing hookmeo is that i'm trying to
solve a domain problem that isn't very
well defined and what i was hoping is
that i would kind of cut my presentation
a little bit short and i want to open
this up to a q a so we can kind of talk
about web hooks and the web hook
environment i know a lot of people here
have had to deal with this in
applications and i'm kind of curious and
get some feedback about you know what do
you think of web hooks what do you think
hookio would you ever consider using a
service like it and what features would
you like to see
so um if anyone has any questions i'd
like to uh kind of turn this into a q a
if that's yeah
anybody
where do you sort of see the first
potential use of this in like an
industry right because right now you
just have it as a more of a private
project or public project rather but
where do you see it kind of being hooked
into
so if you go to hook.io there's actually
a section called business ideas
there's a lot of businesses right now
web businesses that i consider a subset
of hokio functionality if you look at
something like bitly like a url
shortening service in hokio all that is
is a listener for a unique url and then
an action which redirects to another url
so in theory you know you just kind of
replicated the basic functionality of
bitly right there and the way that web
hooks work in hookieo is that you can
chain them so you have the initial
action of an incoming url and then a
redirection so you could put a couple of
hooks in between and then you could
start logging things like analytics um
you know where they came from
and um so that's like one specific use
case but um there's probably like eight
or ten of them on there there's a lot of
uh services right now like people are
parsing uh and scraping html from sites
and then they're aggregating that data
and then pushing it somewhere like
hookio could really take over a lot of
that stuff
another question
so the general purpose of it is to kind
of monitor a web page out there and then
when
you have some rules or
something that
once it catches that then you perform
some function or action on that which
can be just about anything sure so
monitoring a web page would be um uh
polar you'd be pulling like a static
resource so that's one way that hook you
can listen for things but um again it
can also do sockets so yeah you're just
like listening for some event and then
you're just going to perform some
arbitrary action so a lot of the use
cases i think will be for scraping like
you're saying you can start aggregating
information from a static page or kind
of turn it dynamic so suppose there was
a website you really liked going to and
you wanted to get updates from it but
they didn't have an rss feed and they
didn't have a mailing list or anything
like that you could set up a poller to
check that page and then when the
content updated you could fire an action
maybe send email and then it would send
you the contents of the page
so
of course so um in one of the future
versions of hookia we haven't really
planned it out i want to make hookio
itself a pub pub sub bub um node i guess
and i don't think it would be very
difficult to do because to just push
those messages back and forth is you
know we already have most of the
functionality established
yeah another use case would be that
population would be for
like is the api up.org or something like
that yeah or i mean if
we just do a lot of unit testing at work
and so
we always do the testing prior to
pushing the code out but once it's out
there if you know something changes if
you're including javascript from another
page that you're using and that's
failing to render something but i guess
this wouldn't this would be pre-rendered
javascript but uh yeah
definitely um are there any other
questions
can you do a demo
um yeah i can show the live site i was a
little hesitant to do a demo hopefully
nobody's taken it down yet
so this is the live site right now i'm
going to probably load up the local
version
so there's a few things going on here uh
the site's down so we'll see if this is
up
okay so we have some api unit tests i
think the last one is failing right now
awesome
so again kind of the mantra when
something happens do something else so
in this case we'll say um
a hookie url visit
i'll just say
blah and then we'll say do something
else and then we could say
perform arbitrary http request
or we can say send an email this is
always fun yeah
so i don't i don't think i have send
mail set up on this machine but the idea
would be is you you know you configure
the listener and then you configure the
action it gives you a little pretty
print confirmation of what's about to
happen here you have your
webhook object you have the listener and
then you have the actions array so the
listener is going to be http
and you're going to listen for the path
of blah so this means an incoming http
request with this matching path and when
that happens we're going to perform
these actions which is going to be send
email with the values on barack squires
from president obama hokia was awesome
what's a protocol and what's an action
here
okay so this is uh the protocol would be
the type
so the type is the protocol http and the
action protocol would be send email so
in the web hook definition the listener
is going to be listening
using the http protocol which we've
defined with these configurations
and then the send email for the action
is going to be using the send email
protocol which is a very thin wrapper
for my email protocol
which we could probably abstract into
something else
and uh yeah and then it's gonna send it
out with this definition
that answers your question
and then um yeah so
you create this
confirm successful hook is successful
and then if we go to front slash blah
it found the hook and right now i don't
think it's actually performing the
action it's just kind of bringing it up
and dumping it and that's the action id
so
any other questions
i'm curious as to exactly how we get
from listening to like actually scraping
content like for footballing over a
website
can you give me an email so sure yeah so
um it's a little hard to explain without
you know a concrete example to show you
but the idea would be is that when
something happens you would say on a
timer
right so you say every 30 seconds
i want to perform an arbitrary http
requests right
so now what we haven't really set up yet
and which we're really working on for
the second version for the scraping and
the server side dom parsing would be on
the timer
this would hit the url every 30 seconds
and then we would have another hook
uh that would be chained onto this so
when the response came back and the
timer fired we would say take the
payload from that http request and then
perform some custom validation or
parsing on it and then based off that we
can fire another web hook
obviously just chain them all together
yes that's um i i didn't really go over
it here but that's really where it's
going to be going is some flow control
you know many listeners to many actions
and then you can create complex chains
so by creating simple web hooks in a
chain you can really make some awesome
functionality and then of course you can
start splitting the chain
totally so there's two approaches here
um you could easily just set up two hook
your instances completely separately and
then make them communicate with each
other through restful web hooks that's
kind of the cheat you could also i've
been kind of thinking about i know that
um rick over there has been working on
something called dealer.js
so like i'm definitely thinking of being
able to set up clusters of hookio
servers and actually have them
communicate maybe like you know through
a tcp socket opposed to doing http
requests so there's nothing available
right now but that's definitely planned
for the future
anybody else are we done
great well uh thanks a lot i'm really
glad you guys voted for me and i got the
opportunity to speak here and um yeah
check out the check out the site hook.io
and uh check out check me out on github
marac
and thank you
you